et hockey sans registre des deux côtés
you les potes j'espère que vous allez
bien alors déjà si vous n'avez pas vu la
vidéo sur les vidéos youtube qui sont un
petit peu chiante et sais où je parle de
l'engloutissement des singularités
je vous invite à la regarder parce que
cette vidéo il fait référence
il ya quelques semaines voire quelques
mois après cette vidéo sur les vidéos
chante il y a une fille qui m'a envoyé
un message on va l'appeler jade pour des
questions de d'anonymat elle aussi
russes j'ai adoré la dernière vidéo
merci beaucoup et je me suis tout de
suite reconnu par rapport à ma façon de
consommer du multimédia mais aussi de
façon plus surprenante
tu m'as apporté des réponses sur des
questions plus personnelles en parlant
de l'engloutissement des singularités
j'ai 21 ans et comme un peu tout le
monde je consomme des relations à
travers différentes plateformes et ha
tinh d'heure apple ça à faire environ
deux ans et maintenant j'ai l'impression
que plus personne ne sort du lot et je
passe très vite à autre chose
est ce que tu sais ce qui pourrait aider
à faire en sorte de retrouver la
singularité de ce que l'on observe alors
déjà merci beaucoup pour ton message est
en train de mettre le doigt sur un truc
qui est super intéressant qui est qu'en
fait ce qu'on a vu de sur l'audiovisuel
avec youtube netflix et ça s'applique
sur plein de choses et j'ai l'impression
que ce qui est en train de t'arriver
c'est ce que certains psychologues
américains appellent le dating burnout
c'est que j'appelle crottes de nez voilà
tout va bien alors qu'est ce
burn out en gros tu deviens moins
disponibles emotionnellement tu vas à
plein de déité tout mais tu ressens rien
pour eux et puis en fait tu sais même
pas si c'est à cause d'eux ou c'est toi
qui n'est plus capable d'avoir des
sentiments ton amour propre et fragile
et tu te sens un petit peu désespéré
triste en fait des heat et devient un
petit peu comme une tache comme une
corvée mais tu continue parce que tu dit
mieux vaut ça plutôt que d'arrêter
d'essayer
soit je suis à côté de la plaque en
expliquant ce que c'est le dating leurs
notes soit ça te parle et vu le message
que tu m'as envoyé
je suis à peu près sûr que tout ça ça te
parle le truc c'est que les applis
dating elles faussent totalement notre
manière de gérer les relations
aujourd'hui quand je dis itunes 9
alors je parlais de manière générale
quand tu d itunes 9 août eu des hits un
mec en fait au moindre petit doute au
moindre petit truc qui te gêne à la
moindre incertitude
tu seras tenter d'aller des idées
quelqu'un d'autre parce que c'est
beaucoup plus facile de faire ça que de
gérer cette incertitude là et s'y
confronter or si tu fais que ça tu va
enchaîner les days et tu vas jamais
trouvé cette singularité que tu
recherches
évidemment je ne suis pas en train de
dire que c'est ce que tu fais mais je en
train d'essayer de donner une réponse
qui va parler au maximum de gens et
forcément des gens qui font ça je pense
à moi c'est ce que j'ai fait pendant
longtemps
ouah ouah hockey non non mais c'est une
façon de parler bien évidemment que je
suis pas c'est pas mon style quoi ouais
ouais reste bien tranquille make way
c'est un ouf les tout coup je vais
partager quelques conseils que j'ai pu
trouver que je trouve assez pertinents
l'un d'eux c'est de ne pas se projeter
trop long terme tu vois le genre
notamment sur ces applis là parce que si
on t'a beaucoup d'attentes et tu te mets
un stress assez élevé qui va t'en
empêcher de ressentir des émotions
positives et c'est donc l'idée c'est
plutôt te demander est ce que cette
personne j'ai envie de la déité dans les
prochaines semaines les prochains mois
et il faut aussi que tu acceptes les
incertitudes parce qu'ils font partie de
l'expérience
un autre conseil des professionnels ça
peut être essayé d'arrêter complètement
en fait genre de décrocher un peu ces
applis l'a essayé de rencontrer les gens
différemment en disant à tes potes que
tous cherchent quelque chose
n'allant des arrières mois d activité
sportive des clubs des machins apprendre
la zumba j'en sais rien mais je suis sûr
qu'à plein de façons de rencontrer et
peut-être même dans les commentaires de
cette vidéo qui sait après je trouve que
tu utilises un mot qui est super
important dans ton message
c'est le verbe consommé tu dis je
consomme des relations à travers
différents réseaux et ça ça fait penser
à une sociologue israélienne qui
s'appelle eva et blues qui était ya pas
longtemps sur france culture et c'était
super intéressant
en gros elle nous explique que les sites
et les applis de rencontre elles ont
transformé les relations amoureuses en
marché sur le marché de l'amour est en
fait quand on est face à tous ces
profils c'est comme si on était face à
un étalage et on voit la possibilité de
choix qui s'offrent à nous j'en prends
conscience de ce choix de toutes les
possibilités
alors que d'en passer potentiellement se
rencontrer genre deux personnes par an
en disant tu avais une vingtaine de
personnes ne paient pas cette conscience
de des possibles quoi du choix immense
au passage ce choix en plus il a assez
limité parce que j'étais tu vois tous
ces profils tu dirais en fait ouais j'ai
le choix de ouf
déjà c'est pas tous les profils des vols
de toi ok ensuite au final sur ces
profils à deux kits aurait vraiment
envie le choix se retrouve finalement
très très limité je pense du coup pour
elle le sujet romantique ressemble de
plus en plus aux sujets économiques pour
qui la possibilité du choix définis son
individualité
elle disait d'ailleurs que dans le
domaine de la consommation en fait plus
on a deux choix et moi en a deux choix
parce que plus on est confus en fait on
arrive à un stade où on voit trop de
petites différences entre les objets et
du coup c'est différent cela on n'arrive
pas à les évaluer et on n'arrive pas à
savoir si elles sont importantes pour
nous on parle de l'information ouverte
et elle rajoute qu'elle avait lu des
recommandations de chercheurs qui disait
que voilà il fallait pas voir plus de
neuf profils différents par jour parce
qu en fait au delà ont été incapables de
distinguer les différences quoi on avait
atteint notre stade 2 il faut mais chez
nous vers l'aude et ça ça me fait
beaucoup penser à ce que je vous ai dit
sur les vidéos youtube voilà jade
j'espère que ça va aider à retrouver
cette singularité chez les gens que tu
rencontres
encore une fois il ya pas une seule
solution jahia y en a plein il faut
juste que tu trouves celle qu'il
correspond le plus parce que c'était pas
du tout en recherche de quelqu'un en
fait pour poser tu veux juste keynes est
possible aussi j'espère que ce genre de
vidéos je réponds à un petit commentaire
ou un petit message qu'on m'avait envoyé
vous plaît si ça vous plaît dites moi
parce que j'aurais potentiellement un
autre sur un message
j'ai reçu par rapport à la vidéo sur
l'ennui et tout ça c'est sûr le prisme
de la relation hétéro je sais pas parler
de relations homos parce que c'est
quelque chose que je connais très mal
j'imagine que c'est le même
problématique mais peut-être pas du tout
du coup n'hésitez pas à partager ça dans
les commentaires
dernière chose merci pour vos retours
sur une image une histoire effectivement
c'est la fin de la saison il ya eu 11
vidéo
la playlist je la mets là pour ceux qui
veulent ce bin's watch et le truc
beaucoup de retours positifs
ça fait plaisir je sais pas s'il y aura
une saison 2 mais en tout cas c'était
cool à faire et c'était cool de parler
d'un truc totalement différent sur ma
chaîne si vous aimez ce genre de truc où
on parle d'une image d'une photo etc
j'ai trouvé une chaîne où le gars fait
ça donc je mets le lien en description
aussi pouvait les tchèques un coup
d'oeil qu'il n'y a pas énormément de vue
ou d'abonnés donc ça ferait un petit
coup de pouce qui lui ferait bien
plaisir je pense et enfin pour
l'anecdote les filles que vous voyez sur
la miniature et ben résiste pas elles
ont toutes été générés par intelligence
artificielle mais ça on en reparle une
prochaine fois
love is ciao